c'est une photo de la cathédrale du
puy-en-velay pourquoi j'ai choisi cette
photo parce que l'europe s'est pas
d'abord des directives s'est pas d'abord
une organisation administrative pour
nous l'europe c'est d'abord une culture
c'est une civilisation c'est une
identité et à force de l'oublier on a
laissé le communautarisme changer notre
mode de vie par rapport à ce défi il ya
ce soir plusieurs attitudes
il ya ceux qui veulent des construire
l'europe il ya ce al'inverse qui
s'accommode que l'europe devienne
multiculturelle et que petit à petit
elle perde son identité avec
françois-xavier bellamy on est la seule
liste à croire dans l'europe mais une
europe des racines qui défendent ces
frontières qui assume la réaffirmation
de son identité et qui surtout retrouve
l'envié de transmettre à nos enfants la
fierté de ce que nous sommes c'est ça
l'europe pour laquelle onze mois
monsieur bayrou avec monsieur macron
c'est juste protection européenne madame
le pen c'est juste protection nationale
tout ce qu'ont pensé qu'au contraire il
faut articuler on est les seuls à faire
cette proposition une double protection
de nos frontières
une protection européenne d'abord parce
que c'est une évidence qu'il faut que
l'europe nous aide à protéger la
frontière grecque la frontière italienne
la frontière espagnole
parce que les gens qui passent par là
ensuite arrive nécessairement chez nous
et c'est d'ailleurs une des choses que
je ne comprends pas madame le pen vous
vous êtes systématiquement opposés à la
construction d'une défense européenne de
nos frontières
c'est un de nos points de désaccord la
deuxième chose c'est que nous pensons
par contre qu'il faut aussi que la
france ait la maîtrise sur la question
de l'immigration illégale de ceux qui
rentrent ou qui ne rentre pas à
l'intérieur de son territoire
ce qu'a expliqué monsieur macron c'est
que ce qu'il fallait c'était répartir
les migrants entre les pays européens
précisément votre question ce qu'il a
dit c'est qu'il fallait créer des
centres de demandes d'asile
supplémentaires sur le sol européen
nous ce qu'on croit c'est qu'il faut
faire l' inverse les demandes d'asile
doivent être faite de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée aujourd'hui ce qu'on a fait
c'est condamner une prime allant très
irrégulière sur le sol européen et nous
pensons que c'est une folie
l'incarnation c'est quand même ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en france depuis deux
ans notre pays a le record de délivrance
de ces titres de séjour et ça c'est
depuis l'élection des maires ça a
expliqué à celui qui prend sa voiture et
qui fait 10 km pour aller travailler que
c'est lui le pollueur nous ce qu'on veut
en matière de développement durable
c'est qu'on se fixe des priorités les
priorités c'est d'abord de retrouver la
maîtrise par rapport aux importations de
pays qui ne respectent pas nos règles
la taxe carbone que le gouvernement a
décidé de mettre en application en 2018
surtout ceux qui vont travailler que
leur voiture tous ceux qui prennent leur
voiture elle est toujours en oeuvre
toujours pas pénaliser le pouvoir
d'achat des français et à linverse on
n'a rien fait pour les produits importés
à l'arrivée c'est le même air c'est la
même eau c'est la même planète et donc
nous ce qu'on veut c'est retrouver le
bon sens et commencer par pénaliser ce
qui est fabriqué dans des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos règles
au bout de deux ans aujourd'hui jamais
sans doute l'europe n'a été aussi
fragmentée et vous avez été l'acteur de
cette dislocation
donc vous pouvez pas ensuite venir ici
en disant on va être le rempart de
l'europe
la réalité c'est que l'europe n'a jamais
été aussi faible et la france jamet
aussi isolée à cause des rodomontades et
des leçons qui ont été administrées par
emmanuel macron jamais dans notre
histoire
on a été à ce point là aussi gravement
abîmée avec le pire déficit budgétaire
de la zone euro et donc moi je suis
content quand on fait des promesses
qu'on est incapable de tenir parce que
promettre qu'on va baisser les impôts
alors qu'on n'a pas fait d'économies sur
la dépense publique comme le
gouvernement était incapable de le faire
ça n'est pas réaliste dans cette
élection cette fois-ci vous avez le
choix
dans cette élection il faut voter par
rapport à vos convictions
c'est le moment de vous exprimer c'est
le moment de vous faire réentendre et je
m'adresse à tous les français la liste
que nous portons avec françois-xavier
belhani cette liste d'union de la droite
et du centre c'est la seule qui porte un
projet européen autour de conviction
clair la fin de l' élargissement la
volonté de retrouver une europe des
projets une europe qui défendent ces
frontières qui retrouve l'audace
économique qui puisse lutter contre le
gaspillage de l'argent public et
l'europe aussi qui réaffirme ses racines
chrétiennes son identité face à
l'islamisme
notre liste est la seule qui pourra
faire entendre cette voix au parlement
européen et c'est la seule alternative
entre un pouvoir qui a failli et le
chaos des extraits